Well, thank you all for watching.
You
your
Oh, thank you. I didn't I didn't see anything. I don't even have
chat open. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm almost 30 minutes late. I'm sorry. I can't even
I don't have the I don't have the stream moments tab open. Hold on. I like I woke up and as
soon as I saw people were waiting for me, I was like, Oh, shit. Fuck. I need to start
the stream. I wasn't even sure if I was going to stream today. Um, thank you for the 20
gifted. Okay, there. Thank you for the 20 gifted. Let me make sure I'm on the right
microphone setting. I'm super unorganized right now. I'm so sorry. Okay, I am. Thank you so
much for the 20 gifted. That's so nice of you. Let me open chat. I'm like really sweaty
because I got ready for the stream super fast because I had to. I had to set it up, you
know, because it's a foot cam today. Um, oh my God, why are there so many people watching?
This is not going to be that extravagant of a stream. Thank you for being here though.
Scuff stream. Let's go. It's gonna be good one. I don't know about. Oh my God. It could have
taken a day off if you needed. I wasn't sure I was I was being really, um, what's the word
when you can't make a decision indecisive. I was being really indecisive and so I took
a nap and then I woke up at two minutes after the stream was supposed to start and I checked
the stream and I see that I think maybe strong or someone rated me and I was like, shit, shit.
I feel bad for canceling now. But thank you for the $20. Congrats on 20k at this rate.
You'll be at 30k before you know it. I am at 30k. Are you gaslighting me right now? Am I
not at 30k? I am at 30k. Thank you though. Probably cuz feet, cutest feet on YouTube.
I did make my feet pretty. Um, I hope you'll be able to see it. The nail polish kind of
looks great but it's supposed to be purple. I don't know. I hope you'll like it. My phone
might die and so I might lose tracking. I realize I don't even have my ring light on.
Let me turn that on. Hold on.
There we go.
Okay, before you know it. Okay, I put the sound alerts back on.
One.
I'm drinking gamer stuff. It sounds so weird to say but I feel like I should say it cuz I
actually enjoy, I really enjoy lean. Lean is my favorite flavor out of all the other flavors.
50k soon? I don't know maybe. It would be nice. It would be nice. I don't know when.
I feel like I might slow down because I have so many things that I didn't finish. I didn't
finish the 10, I didn't even finish the 10k ducky art.
Why are you guys freaking out that I like lean? Is lean a drug? I don't even know.
How are you feeling Amy? Like shit. Like shit.
Okay, let me back away from the drawing pad here. Hopefully my camera is working.
We're about to find out. Oh it is working. Let me move out of the way.
Okay, I'm kind of far from the mic now.
Hi, there they are. It does look gray. I'm sorry. It looks gray.
So I'm wearing like mom yoga pants. I found them at Goodwill and they were really cheap
and I need yoga pants. So I'm wearing like the really mom looking yoga pants.
I painted my nails they're supposed to be purple and sparkly but they look gray.
And also I have like really old nail polish from when my aunt did my nails but they were
supposed to be purple. What the fuck? Alright, well they're gray.
But they are sparkly at least. So that's nice. And there's my feet.
I'll give you a close up because I know you like them. I have some scabs on them.
Because it's summer and I get a lot of bugs in my room.
Don't worry, brothers and y'all, I'm just using my powers.
Thank you for the five dollars. What do you mean using your powers?
Because it's summer and I get a lot of bugs in my room and they bite me.
I got some scars from the bug bites, especially on this one.
Double audio? Wait, did someone do it? Double audio? Uh oh.
Is that better? What the fuck? Was my camera capturing my audio?
Oh, I'm so sorry. Double audio. Thank you for letting me know. There we go. Is this better?
It's better. Okay, it's fixed. Okay, okay. Sorry for the double audio.
I had no clue that this camera captured audio too. Was it good audio at least or was it bad?
It was probably bad. Okay.
I gotta stop turning off my phone. I need this phone for chat.
It was yummy audio? I don't think it was. I don't think it was.
I gotta take a moment to rest because as soon as I got up, I started running around everywhere to get this stream up.
Chat is fixed though. OBS fixed chat.
It wasn't bad, sounded echoey. Okay, that's good.
Okay, well good to know that my, um, I don't like how you can see my, I don't like how you can see my, um, my shadow there.
Okay, let me come in a little more. Let me back you up.
I'm using, someone bought me pink puppy pads or not a puppy pad. These are, um, P pads. Someone bought me pink P pads and, um, now I'm using them for the background of the stream.
I'm, okay, hold on. Let me adjust the camera. I'm going to turn it off though.
One moment. I feel like I gotta bring it closer to the pewter.
And that's why I turned off the camera, because it just fell over. That would have been bad.
Oh, over.
Ah, no, not my mom yoga pants. You saw them. Oh, they're so ugly.
I'm so embarrassed of them.
There we go.
That's better.
Okay.
Good enough for me. I don't care. Right.
Is the background music good? Is it quiet enough? Loud enough? Let me check chat.
Wife.
No.
Okay.
If you're embarrassed, take them off. No.
No.
I will keep my mom yoga pants on. I don't like it. I don't like showing the shape of my legs.
Okay.
Um, so, basically today, we're going to, um, oil up my feet. And by oil up, I mean, lube up, because I don't have oil.
Because I don't have oil, so I'm just using the lube from a member stream. I hope that's okay.
And I have a bunch of, um, I have a bunch of Crayola markers in here, and that's what I'm going to use to draw.
And I'm just going to try, that's why I have this puppy pad out is so that, um, if I like spill the juices around me, then, um, they won't go on the floor. They'll go on the pup pad.
I call it a puppy pad, but really it's for like geriatric patients when they piss and shit themselves.
Okay, let's lube up my feet now.
Yeah, I'm so smart.
Yeah, it's going to be messy, but, um, you have a pack maxing.
That's such a funny way to put it. I'm going to use, uh, crème brûlée, because I remember that tastes good.
I don't know if I should have my rats out for this. Should I?
I'll open the cage.
If they want to come out, they can. If they don't, they won't.
I don't know.
Rats get you banned? Is it pet safe? I mean, it's human safe, so I assume it's pet safe. Rats can eat basically, oh, I don't even have napkins.
Uhhh.
Okay, I'll go get napkins. I wasn't prepared for this. I'll go get napkins. I'll be right back.
I'm back. I was talking to myself because my mic was muted.
Silhouette reveal? No fucking way. It's rough. Don't look at it. Don't look. Keep your eyes closed.
Okay, um, should we start? Okay, I gotta lube up the feet first, okay.
Let me get you a good, uh, I mean, moisturize them. Oil them. Oh yeah, there we go.
Oh my. This is allowed on YouTube, right?
Is this allowed? It looks kind of...
Oh my god, they're so shiny! Oh my god!
Oh my god! I gotta hold them up like this. Oh wow. Oh, I'm falling over. Okay, there. Oh wow. Look at that. They're so shiny.
Should I add some more? I feel like they could be shinier. Ew, that's so gross. That's gross. Let's make them shinier. Hold on, let me show you.
I'll rub it around. Make this one shinier too. There you go. That's so gross. Okay, so now my feet are sufficiently, um, wet.
It's gonna get all over the canvas, for sure. It's already all over the canvas. How am I gonna draw like this? Should I choose a different...
Maybe I should choose a different page because this one already has oil all over it.
Entirely not suggestive. No, they're just shiny. I just greased them up. They're almost reflective. I just greased them up a little bit. Nice, right?
Okay. Now, I'll take a couple suggestions from chat about what to draw.
If the canvas was on an ankle? Ew, there's hair on the canvas. It's not really canvas, it's just a sketch pad.
A pinpal? Okay. I'll do a pinpal first, then. If that's what you suggest, I mean, um, you can see my shadow so much.
Oh my. How lewd. Let me try drawing on this side of the canvas because it's not as wet. Alright. I should have been drunk for this. It would have been more entertaining.
Let me get the green out and the black out and the orange? Orange.
Is that all the colors I need? I think that's all the colors. I'm drawing this from memory so I don't... No, I think I need red, too.
Red. I'm drawing it from memory so I don't remember much. I'll try to keep chat with me.
Drunk and slippery? Peak entertainment.
Let's start with the orange. Ew, there's a hair. Oh my god. My room is filled with hairs because it's my room and I'm disgusting and so I don't vacuum that often.
Oh, it's really slippery. Oh, it's really, really slippery. Okay. Okay, let's start with the head. Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm gonna get so many cramps right now. I can feel one coming on. Oh, it's not that bad. It's cute.
And then you got like ear holes. Okay, that ear hole is kind of bad. Another ear hole. Alright, alright. I think that's all the orange because you're a pumpkin. Or should I draw the pumpkin lines?
Anyways, how was your day? Mine was meh.
How was your day? Mine was just meh. I woke up. I made a coffee.
I got some nice chairs on my, recently I got some nice chairs on my porch because I went on vacation to the beach and at the Airbnb they had chairs on their porch and I was like, wow, it's just so nice to sit here in the morning. Is this gray?
It's black. Why is it so gray? What was I saying?
They had like chairs on their porch and I was like, wow, so nice to sit here in the morning and like chill on the porch and I was like, I need to get myself some chairs on my porch and that's what I did and it's really nice actually.
I definitely recommend putting chairs on your porch if it's big enough. And it's actually not too expensive either. I thought it was going to be like $500 to get some chairs and a table but it really wasn't that bad.
I feel like I should get the camera closer. You guys are kind of far, right?
Thank you for becoming a member of Moni. Make that 34K big bro. I'm so proud of you. Thank you.
I don't have small grippers actually. They're very normal sized. They're very average sized. Let me get you closer. Hold on.
There we go. That's better.
Now you can see it closer.
Is it even better? Did it change? Did anything change right now?
Oh yeah, green. Green fell on the floor. How convenient. What else did I do? I woke up, had my coffee. I recorded an audio for next. I can't pick it up.
There we go. I did it. I recorded an audio for next month. It won't open now because it's so greased up.
Come on. Okay, I got it open. I recorded an audio for next month. What else did I do? I cried.
And then I went to sleep after because I was tired. And then I woke up and now I'm here drawing with my toes.
I feel like we need a darker green. That's not dark enough.
If you keep hearing fart sounds, it's my cheer. I don't fart that often. I don't fart nearly as much as I burp.
Okay, let me make it darker green.
There we go. Completely followed the original outline for sure.
Sudden Barrage of Kisses. Congrats on 20k and Way Beyond. You're doing great. I love you, little sis. Thank you.
You guys are really, thank you. I'm really sorry for having to cancel stream yesterday. I don't like to cancel. I feel bad canceling.
Thank you for understanding. Why does it look nice, doesn't it? It's because I'm really good at drawing.
So it transitions to every single part. Ew, my feet look so disgusting because it picks up all the dirt.
I'm really good at drawing, so it spreads to the rest of my body too.
Every part, every single part of my body is good at drawing. Can you tell? Can you tell?
And then, I think I have to do the rest of the body with black, right? You're like, mostly black.
The penpal is melting? No, he's not. He just took an edible.
Your armpits? Even your armpits? Sure. Yeah, maybe one day.
I don't know if I'll do a drawing with my armpit stream. That would be really difficult. That would be really, really...
Get this fuck-ass hair out of here. That would be really difficult to draw with my armpit.
And it'd be even more difficult to show it without just fucking base-camming it up.
Oh, shit. There we go.
Cut.
And then you got a little tail.
Now I have to remember how the rest looks.
He's rotten? No, he's not rotten. He's not rotten.
Don't insult him like that. He's very ripe and ready to be bred.
He's very ripe. Don't call him rotten.
Or a bit fatter than I remember. No! I think the chubby-ness is cute. I like the roundness.
Cats are cute when they're chubby.
Looks like he has the shakes. What's shakes? What do you mean the shakes?
He's not shaken. He's completely normal.
I'm trying to pick up this orange.
Should I take a break in between drawing to oil up the feet even more?
My feet are covered in hair now!
And now I have to figure out how to open this marker when it's all greased up.
Fun fact, I'm ambidextrous with my feet. Yep. I'm just as good.
I'm just as good at drawing with my left feet than I am with my right feet.
Okay, I genuinely don't remember. I know you have stitches on your feet, right?
And these ones are white. Your hands are white.
Chat talking some mad shit for people without any feet?
Exactly! Exactly!
This is what you look like, you know, I'm drawing you. You're insulting yourself by talking shit like that.
And then you have like some orange bits somewhere.
I think your tail is orange too, actually.
Ignore all the disgusting hair on the canvas.
You have left feet and right feet? Do you not?
This is my left one and this is my right one.
Do you not have left feet and right feet?
Do you only have left feet?
You only have one foot?
That's true, the average amount of feet in people is less than two.
And the average amount of hands too!
Or maybe it could be...
No, it's probably less than two. There's probably more people without a hand or a foot than there are people with an extra one, right?
Oh fuck, my markers keep falling!
Pop on one foot like the Pixar lamp? Why? Why would I do that?
Why would I do that?
Grease check? Still amply greased?
And you have... I think it's like on the paw?
The stitches are on the paw? Maybe?
Maybe?
Okay, I tried. I tried. And then you have a heart! You have a broken heart on your chest, right?
The average amount of brains in a person is more than one and that's kind of weird.
Are you talking about like conjoined twins or something?
Why is the average amount of brains on a person more than one? Do some people have two brains?
I know I have less than one probably.
Nails look nice, thank you!
The raw average is actually three, but only because they counted Hans George who was born with over 10,000 hands.
Are you trolling me right now?
Who the fuck is Hans George?
I'm I, I'm I, what do you mean I'm I?
Am I?
Ambi dextrous footsies? Yeah, did I say something weird or wrong?
Ami? Ami what? Pregnant women?
Is your heart on the... which side is your heart on?
I think it's on this side.
Wait, but are we counting pregnant women in the average count of hands, too?
And feet, because then at that point they would also have...
Then at that point, if we count them in the average amount of hands and the average amount of feet, then it would also be bigger than two.
Like when do... my feet are so shaky.
When do pregnant women count and when do they not count?
Okay, I tried.
That's your heart.
My heart is with you and me?
I don't think pregnant counts. That's what I'm saying. It shouldn't count.
Let me put the pin in you.
Only when it matters to make funny statistics.
Okay, okay.
Okay, so it only counts when you want it to count then, huh?
Okay.
Also, you know what's really funny? The script I did today...
The script I did today was...
Paisu-di? Is that how it's pronounced?
Um...
And I just thought it was funny because the stuff I was saying in the script I was like, damn.
This doesn't apply to real life.
I showed my... my bitties like way before I knew I was gonna do this script.
So I'm like, you like my flat chest?
You like my...
Oopsies.
I didn't expect to ever do a script like that because there's...
Just imagine, just imagine.
We'll be a little bit de-lulu together.
Alright, there's a pinpal.
Did I... I... Last time I drew with my feet on stream, I signed every, um...
I signed every drawing at the bottom, so...
You know, I gotta sign this piece of artwork...
With my name because...
The people in the future are gonna need to know the name of this wonderful artist.
There she is.
Amy.
Amy, let me fix that.
There we go.
Alright, let me rip it off.
Or not rip it off. Let me show you. Let me show you first.
There it is.
Amy.
There's the pinpal.
It looks like shit.
Okay.
Next page.
What are you saying?
Artist. It's cute. It is cute. Very cute.
Good.
Looks like a five-year-old male made it. It looks cute.
Why do you have to specify that a five-year-old boy made it?
A five-year-old girl could have done just as much of a shit job as this.
It's perfect. Thank you. It is perfect.
It is perfect. Fridge-worthy. It's museum-worthy. It's not fridge-worthy.
Fridge-worthy is an insult to my artistry.
This is gonna be worth something. Big money. It's already worth something.
It's already worth big money.
Every girl can do pysody depending on the position.
I'm supposed to be completely flat. I don't know what they were thinking.
I think you just rub against my chest.
Draw your rats.
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Mr. Sister Kisser Disco took $6.90. I like Big Ditty.
But I'll play the xylophone with my giggle stick and the ribs on your flat chest.
Oh my god!
You'll play the xylophone with your giggle stick on your flat chest.
What an image.
What an interesting image to think of.
I was not thinking of it that way.
It's called nicety.
No, because there's nada there.
What's your favorite MLP character? I've already drawn my favorite.
I don't want to draw her again. I can show you.
I don't know if I have it here. Hold on.
Here it is.
I drew Minty with my feet.
Look, it's Minty.
My favorite MLP character is Minty.
This is an old drawing I have of her with my feet.
Isn't she precious? I love Minty.
I love Minty.
Your uterus crashed. Reboot it.
Hire that man. Hire that man to do what?
Write scripts for us?
I guess he would fit right in, wouldn't he?
Draw Liberty? I've already drawn her, too.
I don't want to be drawn. I've already drawn.
I'll draw the viewer girls.
Sure, yeah.
I can do that. I can do that.
They won't be great.
I think I'll try to draw Stickman viewer girls.
Let me re-lube between sets.
Sets.
Oh no, it's dripping.
Gotta make sure I'm sufficiently moisturized for this.
Alright, there we go.
Refreshed and also have a piece of marker on me.
But still refreshed.
Refreshed.
Right.
Take all your screenshots now.
Okay.
Who should we start with?
Let me get it. Let me try to start with Strani.
She's got pink and green hair.
And her outfit is...
Fuck, what color is her outfit?
I forgot what color Strani's outfit is. Isn't it green?
Okay.
Green mostly.
Okay, I'll get this...
I'll get this...
Seafoam green color.
That matches.
And also black. Where's the black?
Here's the black.
Alright, Strani's coming up first.
Hopefully I have enough space on the canvas for this.
Alright, pull it closer in the middle.
Okay.
I gotta go, like, really...
I'm not gonna draw myself, I'm just gonna draw the other girls.
And Strani's got some...
Some medium-sized bazlingas.
Um...
And then these are gonna be her legs.
Can you hear me good?
The microphone's kind of far from my face.
Maybe I'll turn up the...
I'll turn the...
The what's it called?
The gain up!
Oh, I gotta get this cap.
Hold on.
Hold on, I almost got it.
Come on.
Just get in between.
Oh my god.
Okay, I got it.
Yay!
Ah, fuck!
I just draft it again.
I don't want to bend over to get it.
Okay, I got it a second time.
Can't escape me.
And then she's got green hair with pink tips.
And it's like...
Big bangs, right?
She's got those big bangs.
And the...
Shit.
And the pigtails.
This is rough.
That looks...
It's already looking like Strani.
I could basically leave it there
and you'd probably be able to guess who was Strani.
Here's the pink tips.
It's really hard to get a hold of this marker
because my feet keep slipping down it.
Are her bangs pink too?
I think her bangs are pink too.
Let me add some pink in her bangs.
And she's got those swirly things on the top of her head.
There they are.
And then I'll draw her dress.
Oh yeah, I watched a lot more May Day today.
Which is just a show about...
More plane crashes.
It's just a show about plane crashes.
I watched the one about the pilot that flew out the window.
Basically, he flew out the window because, um...
They replaced the screws.
They replaced the screws in the plane.
And, um...
I think the plane had the wrong screws in them.
My ancestors watching me watch an oiled feed stream.
Skull.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five dollars.
Your ancestors would be proud.
What do you mean?
They'd be very proud.
There it is.
Does she have?
She doesn't have shoes, right?
Does she?
No.
Does she have anything on her legs?
I feel like I'm going to have to do this.
I feel like she has some sort of something on her legs.
But I don't know what.
I think she has like...
Stuff?
Like...
Gills or something?
She got something going on her legs.
That's the something.
Hey there, scrawny.
Leg wraps in pink.
I don't know how those look though.
Wow, it's actually recognizable.
I told you it is.
From the start.
I knew it was going to be recognizable
because my skills never fail.
I've been in this business...
30 years.
And you dared doubt...
my professionalism and my skill.
I could sue you.
For a lot of money.
Because I know how this business works.
I could sue you for defamation.
I'm losing clients because of you.
And you're doubt.
And you're spreading of rumors.
That I'm not good at what I do.
I've seen your fake Google reviews.
On my art.
I've seen them.
I've seen what you've been saying.
Okay, I don't...
Oh shit.
One of my marker tips.
Oh fuck.
What?
Oh.
There it is.
What the hell?
Okay.
Do I not have a brown?
I do have a brown.
I'm going to draw a zero next.
A zero has...
Purple clothes.
Yeah.
And green hair.
And...
This is just proof that I don't remember what any of the girls look like.
What is this talking about?
I'm talking about you.
And giving you...
Yeah.
Giving you a cease and desist.
For your defamation.
I'm talking about all the haters.
That are plotting against me.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm going to try drawing with this foot now.
I feel like I'm low-key kind of better with this foot.
All the haters that are plotting against me.
I see you.
Oh fuck.
It was like really tall.
Um...
I'm going to move her head up here.
She's like really big and tall.
And I'm going to make her boobs.
I don't know.
I'll fix it.
I'll cover it.
Somehow.
Are you sure boobs?
Can you tell that they're boobs?
Can you tell that this says Strani?
It looks more like...
Forks.
Fox?
Okay, well it says Strani.
And then she's got really big hips.
Yeah.
Oh, that's what I'm talking about.
Hot.
Fuck, it keeps slipping.
My feet are hurting because it keeps slipping.
Okay, I just exchanged feet without even trying.
I didn't mean to do that.
Okay?
What was I talking about?
Damn, she thick.
I know she thick.
Family of 20 birthing hits.
Soothe the haters?
Oh, fix it in post?
There is no post.
This is live.
This is a live recording.
There is no post.
Wait, are you wafflin'?
Oh, what are you wafflin' about?
I don't know, man.
I don't know what I'm wafflin' about.
Yeah, I gotta put this on.
Normally I would be paywalling this, you know?
This kind of art.
This kind of this lude.
This lude kind of art.
Normally I would be paywalling this.
But instead I'm giving it to you.
Fuckin' hell, come on.
Oh shit, I drew on the pad.
Give it to me.
But instead I'm giving it to you.
For free.
She has like long hair.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh, that's hot.
Hell yeah.
And then she's got purple clothing
and they're like drapes.
If you could see my feet
and how disgusting they are right now,
like in high res, you'd be disgusted.
And she's got like her boobas out.
And like...
She's got like some sort of...
I know you can see her thighs.
Does she have some sort of body suit?
I don't remember.
Like some sort of body suit.
Sorry, it doesn't cover her Gucci.
It's okay though, it's cuter if the Gucci's out, right?
And then she's got like the...
The drapes.
Cause she's like a goddess.
I realize I forgot to draw her arms.
Does she have shoes?
I don't think so.
She does have some sort of thigh highs, I think though.
I gotta make that more loud so you can hear it.
Oh shit, I gave her a shoe.
She's not wearing shoes.
Sorry, ignore that.
Thank you for becoming a pin pal.
Yeah, easy access.
We wanna see high res disgusting feet.
I don't think the camera is high res enough.
Like you can see the marker.
It looks like caca.
It's the marker.
And some white hair, I don't know where that's from.
Is this string?
I think it's string.
It looks like poop from a butt.
Is that what you wanna see?
There you go.
There's...
Oh, that looks like Azura.
That looks like the word Azura.
And I'm not trying to guess like you into believing that.
Am I drawing with feet cause no hands?
No I have hands.
Is there poop that's not from a butt?
Yeah, there is.
Oh she has horns, I forgot, yeah.
There is poop that's not from a butt.
There's poop from the intestines.
Sorry, there we go, there's her horns.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And she has ears too.
Okay, there's her ears.
It's kinda covered in like...
marker.
There you go.
They're quite soft.
And a little dirty, but...
You guys are so weird.
You're so weird.
And then this one's also covered in marker.
This one I can't turn as much.
Wow.
Oh thank you, feet tickle, Redeem.
You want me to tickle them?
No, I don't think I can really tickle myself.
I need you to tickle me.
I can't tickle myself, it doesn't work.
I don't get ticklish.
Okay.
Self tickles don't work, yeah.
Soft confirmed.
Go wash your feet, stinky.
I'm drying with my feet, of course they're gonna get dirty.
What's next, let's draw?
Let's draw Mercy next.
So Mercy...
Mercy's kinda like...
purple, right?
I don't have many shades of purple.
Dennis came out of the cage, but I don't know if you'll see her.
Does she have pink on her?
We're trying to think what Mercy looks like.
I'm drawing them from memory.
I can't cheat.
She's a little purple.
Purple?
Rats are ticklish if you tickle them they laugh, but it's so high pitched you can't hear it.
I know, I'm actually certified.
I have a certificate from an official university in rat tickling.
I'm a certified rat tickler.
Not to toot my own horn, but um...
I know how to tickle a rat.
Really good.
Purple, scissors, fishnet, thong, that's all I can remember.
Don't cheat, you're making me cheat by telling me what she looks like.
It's gotta be from memory.
There's a hair.
There's a university, I don't remember which one.
That um...
Gives out rat tickling certificates, and it's just an online course.
It's not even a course, it's more like a PowerPoint.
It's just like an online PowerPoint, and you like, I think you take a quiz.
Maybe you don't even take a quiz at the end.
And they just give you a certificate saying you're certified to tickle rats inside of a lab.
Inside of like a lab, basically.
Like if a lab never ever needs a rat tickler, like, you're certified.
And you can show them that as proof.
I don't know if I can send you the link or anything.
I don't know what...
It was a long time ago, but I still have the picture in my phone somewhere.
Of my certification.
In case I ever need to show my certification.
In case of an emergency and a rat needs to be tickled.
I'm ready.
She's got like two strands.
She's got really spiky bangs.
There's her spiky bangs.
Man, you can't even tell what this is.
I think her uniform is like really dark purple too.
Will you tickle pin pals if they're rats?
Yeah.
Of course, I would tickle you even if you're not a rat.
May I ask which university?
Don't doubt my credentials.
It's a real university.
Okay, so she's got like a bra.
And like a shirt.
And like a...
A dress, but only half...
Only like half of the dress, because then it's cut off.
And she's got like a thong.
There's her thong.
I feel like I need to zoom in even more.
You're like, you can't see all the details of my art here.
You can't appreciate all the details of the art.
Hold on.
There we go.
Now you can see all of the details.
details. An effort that I put into this. We started off kind of far away, but now we're
now we're real up close and personal.
Ah, I love lead. I don't even know anything about the drug.
She's got like red, red and white stockings.
I don't, uh, I don't really know anything about any drugs.
Some of my family members do.
Ah, growing up was interesting to say the least.
There's her stripes and then she's got purple shoes.
I know I'm so wholesome and angelic and I don't dabble in the devil's lettuce
or the devil's
powder, the devil's baking soda or the devil's, the devil's
the devil's shrews or the devil's. Is that an M to you? Does that look like an M?
There we go. Mercy or the devil's. Thank you for the dollar. Thank you for the dollar.
The devil's crystals, the devil's crystals or the devil's candy or the devil's soap.
The devil's soap or the devil's, the devil's booger sugar.
The devil's booger sugar. Okay, I'm going to draw Icy and then
and Sheebie's last. Sorry, Sheebie. Icy's like real short.
Anyway, it's back to Mayday because it's become my new favorite thing.
This pilot, like while they were, oh my god, that scared me.
This pilot while they were flying blew out of the, oh thank you for the 100,000 IDR.
I don't know what IDR is. I hope that's not like a bunch of money.
Did you donate like a, oh, they're $637. There we go.
Wow, what is that currency where it's only $6 but it's 100,000? That's crazy.
Oh, Indian rupees. Oh, oh, damn. I don't know how money economics work. Oh, Indonesian rupee.
Last, are you forgetting someone? Oh no, did I?
Strani, Azura, Mercy, Icy, Sheebie and then I'm the sixth one but I'm not going to draw myself.
Oh wait, let me, let me draw her tights.
Indonesian money, Argentinian monopoly money. Why not? Because there's not going to be space on
a canvas and also like, you know, this is fan art. This is fan art. I can't include myself in the fan
art. That's like weird. I don't know. I have no space on this canvas.
I'm drawing them fan art. You know, I don't want to, I don't need to draw myself fan art. I've already
drawn so much fan art of myself. I need to, you know, I need to spread the love, spread my artistic
talents to the other girls. I promise them I would draw them so here it is. I think Icy's
bangs might go the other way but oh well. There's her hair. Nothing wrong with inserting yourself.
Imibezu is an Imibezu hater. I am an Imibezu hater. I hate Imibezu. Fuck that bitch. I hate her.
Her voice is ugly and her model is ugly and she's weird and I don't like her because she
farts on stream and makes weird content and her feet are ugly.
Thank you for the $2.99. You are your own hater. I am my own hater.
Any hate comments you ever see online? That's me on, um, that's me on burner accounts.
Yep, they're all me. Anytime you see a hate comment, it's me hating on myself.
Just to kind of like pretend that I have some haters. Because in reality everyone loves me and
I don't want to, I don't want to make the other veiler girls jealous by not having any haters so
I purposefully hate on myself. I hope no one's taking this seriously. Every hate comment you see
is real. I know some people are weird and like like to like to take things out of proportion.
Every hate comment you see, I mean you probably don't see a lot of hate comments on my videos
because I delete them all. But um, anyone you do see ever is real.
You have a lot of free time then? Of course I do.
I'm a VTuber, of course I have free time. What do you think I do all day? Make content? No.
I make fake hate accounts so I can get so out and hate on myself. Sorry, I'm like...
Here's Icy.
Don't talk about her feet like that.
Liberty is way better. Oh, the amount of comments I get.
Hold on, let me get, let me get, oh fuck. All of my markers are falling.
What was I even saying? Yeah, the amount of comments I get like that is crazy. Also the amount
also the amount of comments that are like, wow. Her voice is so familiar but I don't know where
I've heard it before. I'm sure Strani gets a lot of those comments too. What colors are shebies?
What color is shebie?
She's blonde.
And she wears like a black, she wears like black office attire and red and red.
Yeah, red rope. Yeah, I know. I have a great rem, meh, meh, meh.
I have great memory. All right, let's stick shebie in here. Anyways, I was talking about the,
God, it's getting hot in my room. What type is it? Okay, I was talking about the...
Wait, shebie's taller than Icy. Fuck, I keep doing this.
I'll figure something out. Okay, I kind of made shebie the same way I did this year.
Damn it. The heights are accurate. Ignore the heights. Let's just make this another one of
shebies boobs. There. Basically, the cockpit has windows, right? In a plane.
My feet are getting so tired right now. I have to grip the grip, the strength of the grip I have
on this marker is so freaking strong because I have to grip it so hard for it to not slip
out of my feet, out of my toes. Yeah, the cockpit in the plane has windows and you screw those
windows in with screws and they like, I think they like built the plane with the wrong, I'm so
sorry, please don't fall, with the wrong screw size and so when they were doing maintenance,
they, the engineer used the same screw size and for some reason all those years the screws were
fine but when they replaced it with new screws, it didn't work out and so the
cockpit window like fell out mid-flight and one of the pilots was sucked out the window
but his feet got caught onto the steering wheel and it started pushing the plane downwards
and so they had to grab onto him and move him and then they figured he was probably dead
so they were gonna let go of him, did she be have,
she may have socks right, they were gonna let go of him right but um
if they were gonna let go of him, he was gonna fly into the engine of the plane,
ill my, the palm of my feet are even more gross now, he was gonna fly into the engine of the
plane and that could like send the whole plane downwards you know, what, what does her,
she wears like some sort of shirt right and it goes like underneath,
she wears a shirt underneath and like a bra, she wears a bra for sure,
she doesn't have her whole wampas out, it's like an office shirt, oh fuck,
sorry I see shebe's, shebe's arm is gonna be in your face a little bit
and she's got like some stripes but I'm just gonna color it in fully, um so they were hanging
on to him the whole time while landing the plane and he was just like flailing out the window of
the plane and getting all bloody and stuff because that's like you know dangerous and guess what
the motherfucker lived, he lived and they were, they were gonna let go of him and he lived,
they were hanging on to him the whole time, isn't that crazy, he was like dead for a little bit
though, I think that's how the story goes, he was dead for a little bit,
all right, there's shebe's outfit, let me draw her hair,
it's wild, happy 20k, thank you, only dead for a little bit, yeah you couldn't like die for a
little bit, your heart can stop for a little bit and you're okay, what a Chad,
and me has a new sub, what do you mean by that,
is that from a mean pic, what, no, it's real, it's real and true,
this is like a workout for feet, who needs the gym, except I shouldn't be working out my feet,
I have like really bad feet, what kind of, what does shebe's hair look like,
fuck, what does shebe's, I don't know is she, it's like,
I know she has drills but what do her bangs look like,
I'm gonna cheat, I'm gonna cheat and look at what shebe looks like, Sumi,
oh she has middle bangs, as if like you'll be able to see,
as if you'll be able to tell that I gave her middle bangs and not something else,
because that's what it looks like, sorry shebe, I made your head kind of small,
and here's her big twirls, they're like really big, and this big twirl back there,
it's kind of mixing in with the black a little bit,
and then she's got red on the end of her hair too, red twirls, there,
shebe got that pee head,
she's cheating, she's cheating, cancel her,
uh, write her name, she,
be, there we go shebe,
all right there's my fan art of the five velar girls,
let me show it to you,
that's um, that's Johnny, there's Azura,
okay, there's Azura, that's Mercy, that's Icy, and that's Shebe,
wow they're all so cute together,
it does belong in the museum, take your screenshots now, because those screenshots,
as NFTs are gonna be worth millions,
the, those, oh oops,
the non, the non-fungible token of this is gonna be worth millions in like a year,
so get your, get your free screenshot now, because soon screenshots are gonna be expensive,
yeah the fact that they came in contact with Amy's feet makes them priceless, okay,
let me grab this and flip it over,
I will do one more request, as long as it's simple, I'll do one more request,
hit me, hit me, what do you got,
not bad, it is not bad, it's good, I don't know why people say honestly not bad as if
they're expecting it to be bad, it's not bad at all, your rats, pin pal, I already drew pin pal,
birth of Venus, come on,
Amy Bison,
society,
Bakutek, oh my god,
um,
lots of people are telling me to draw a plane, why do you want me to draw a plane,
I'm scared of planes, if I look at the picture of the plane I'm gonna freak out,
because it's gonna be so accurate to a real life plane,
Amy taking a mating pass,
okay, fine, I'll draw a plane, but it has to be a crash plane, because otherwise
I'm gonna get too scared of a crash plane, I'll draw a crashing in the ocean,
and I'll tell you another story of a crash, a plane crash,
because I've been really into plane crashes lately, and there's another one, I think it's
from the 1950s, I watched it today as I was falling asleep, so I don't remember anything much, but um,
back in the day, they weren't really that good at like,
um, they weren't really that good at like making, like being um,
how do I call it, they weren't very strict about keeping planes away from each other,
like nowadays like they have like, like lanes for planes in the air or something,
like they have altitudes for different planes and lanes, you stay in your lane,
so that way you don't crash into other planes, but um, back in the day they didn't really do that,
because planes were a new thing, and so um, because planes were a new thing, they would try really
hard to like, um, oh that's a thin ass plane, I'll just, I'll draw like multiple parts of the plane,
it's all, it's all cracked up, it's all broken in pieces, and so um, they would like try to make
planes like appealing, because it was so new and so expensive, so they would try to make it like
really um, luxurious, and so they would like go down really close to the ground and like show
people stuff, to be like, ooh look down there, it's the lake of fucking, I don't know, Guatemala,
or look down there, there's the, there's the, what's the highest amount in the world?
I forget the word, there's the highest amount in the world, Everest, they'll be like look down
there on your left is Mount Everest, shit like that, they'll like show, they would like show the
passengers like um, different sites and shit, which nowadays they don't do, they just leave
you up fucking really high in the air, and you, you can't see shit the whole time,
other than like ascending and descending, but um, back then they used to do that,
and this one plane was going over, what are those, in Arizona I think, those um,
those um, those big mountains that, that go down, a pit, a pit, a pit in Arizona, Grand Canyon,
yeah, I called it a pit, the Grand Canyon, at Tibetan Sandbox, I don't even know, I'm trying
to plane crash, um, the, the Grand Canyon, yeah, um, they were like, okay guys, they, they kind of
went down to the Grand Canyon, um, and they also went off course a little bit, they would do that
a lot, and they went off course without really telling people, because they didn't have much
communication back then, with like, um, you know, like the, the, the towers, the plane towers,
I don't know, the communication stations, I don't fucking know, they didn't have much communication
back then with like, the companies, um, the, you know, the tower companies, I don't fucking know
anything about planes, um, so they went off course, and I don't exactly know what happened,
but there was some sort of miscommunication, and when they went off course, they asked to go at a
specific altitude, and I don't remember if they were denied, and they went anyways, or, I don't
know, something went wrong, but they were like, and they were told that another plane was at that
altitude, should I draw a dead people, I'm gonna draw a dead person here, they were told that another
plane was at that altitude, and they were like, okay, that's fine, we'll just make sure to like,
look out for the plane, and if we see it, we'll go further away from it, right?
Fuck, I tried to make an X on his face, that's a dead person, um, but little did they know
that when you're in the clouds, you can't see shit, because you're in the clouds, so um,
what ended up happening is that they saw the other plane, like, right before they were gonna hit it,
and so they hit the other plane, and both planes went down, and everyone fucking died,
like, they tried to avoid it, but it was too late, like, they were, they like, went straight through a
cloud, and on the other side of the cloud was the other plane, there's two dead people,
did the plane hit a giant? No, that's just the two pilots in the plane, it's a really small plane,
it's a really small plane, I mean, where were you in 2001?
I can't even tell you where I was in 2001, I can't tell you,
I can't, it's a, it's a top secret, if I, if I let you know I'd have to kill you,
if I tell you where I was in 2001, I'd have to kill you,
no alibi, you have no alibi, you're the one accusing me,
I didn't even bring up 2001, you brought up 2001,
something original tip $10, do you know the story about the plane that vanished in bad weather
after sending the words dindeck on the radio twice, no one knows what it meant then, and we
still don't know now, hmm, no, thank you for the $10 though, you should send the link,
or not the link, but the name of the,
while drawing the accident with her oiled up feet was not what I was expecting to see today,
but I'm here for a colon underscore grab, no I wasn't drawing the accident, I'm just drawing
an accident, thank you for the $10 though, I'm just drawing an accident, they, they, they both died
in the, in the Grand Canyon, this is in the water, obviously it's in the water, could you not tell
that it's water, you should tell me the name of the, the plane, hold on let me look,
is the plane, is that the plane Tom Hanks from the ocean, I don't know, are you, is this a movie
reference, congrats on 20k, thank you, the pilot's hands were oily and he lost control,
it was driving with his oily feet, the oil is kind of all gone now,
are you gay, why are you acting so gay, something original tipped five dollars, the stand deck one
is 1947, it's an avalanche castry and stardust accident, oh geez that's a long game, okay hold on
let me look it up, 1947, B F A A, Avril, plane castry and stardust accident,
oh wow this is like really niche, oh wow,
okay well thank you for letting me know about it, I guess plane crashes are pretty niche,
most people don't care, but I care, imagine being a pilot with commercial plane and doing loops,
bro I had a fucking dream where I was on, I was on like an airline plane with other passengers and
the, the fucking um, the pilot was trolling me and doing loops, like multiple loops over and over
again and I was freaking the fuck out in this dream because I was like oh my god I'm gonna die,
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I don't even think you
can do loops with, with those big planes, I feel like they're too big and bulky, they're not designed
to do loops, I feel like they would just fall out of the sky if you tried to do a loop, you know,
it had to be like a really big loop, I don't think they could do a loop, I don't know,
has someone here tried, is there any pilots in chat that try to do a loop with one of these
big passenger planes, please, please show yourself, let yourself be known, do a flip,
okay anyways here's the end results of the feet, um, they got markers all over them, obviously,
um, I think some people have a kink for dirty feet though, so that's good and on this side too,
wow, and here's my creations,
I present to you, hold on,
I present to you, plane crash in the ocean by imi bezu,
the vealer girls other than that slut imi bezu, because she doesn't deserve to be in the picture
by imi bezu, and then the pin pal by imi bezu,
three, ah, three masterpieces by imi bezu,
I'm putting the auction for the real drawings at um,
the auctions for the real authentic drawings at a starting price, 1k, each, each, 1k each,
that's the starting prices,
and that's all I have for today folks, let me um, go back to just chatty,
um, I feel so gross now,
oh wow chat's going quick, okay, sorry it's a bit of a shorter stream,
I mean my streams are always a bit of a shorter stream, um,
chat on crack, yeah it does that, I don't know why, it's kind of weird,
like why can't you just be normal, why do you have to do that?
okay rain and nana amano are streaming, I know strani rated nana once,
so I feel comfortable reading her too, or rain,
did you guys hear about the news from yume plus, it's kind of sad,
I kind of, don't tell anyone but um, kind of knew it was coming, I think most people did,
I think most people knew it was coming,
chat reflect streamer, I have good chat, oh you mean like on crack, is that what you mean,
is it just me or is my mouth tracking like way better because I'm closer to the,
closer to the phone now, tends to happen but it's sad, it does tend to happen, doesn't it,
it does tend to happen with a lot of small companies, oh here let me put that down because
I'm closer, it does, that sucks, luckily they can keep their IPs, that's really good because um,
sometimes that doesn't happen, or sometimes it can be a little bit of a
a struggle I guess, a little bit of a struggle to get your IP, so I mean I'm sure it was a little
bit of a struggle for them too, this soon was a bit insane, I thought it was coming any day now,
honestly a lot of companies are are are croaking any day now, when you went, like when I learned
to like how bad it is for some of them, I'm like wow, damn that's crazy, not gonna name names of
course, not including us, not including us, what we won't croak, I will not let us croak, I will
personally not let us croak, will your stream start times ever change, no unless like something
changes in my life, I like this start time, I used to stream at, I used to start stream at 8 p.m,
can you believe that, I used to start at 8 p.m and then I would go for four fucking hours,
I don't have a sort of Santa, Santa money anymore,
Niji keeps making bad decisions, I don't think Niji will go down, at least not,
not the uh Japanese branch, maybe the English branch, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know,
she became a vampire, what if she becomes a vampire, oh well yeah if I become a vampire I'll
start streaming like at night, because that's when vampires are awake, I hope the most it does well
and whatever she wants to do, she seems like a really nice person from what I saw in your stream
with her, I know me too, I haven't been, I've been struggling to reply to DMs um but I do, I do hope
she, she does well, I think she will, she's super talented on her own, like I think whatever she
does she'll do good, she's funny too, she's really funny, did I miss another Vtuber company
to spamming, they were a very small company, it's not, it didn't, it didn't make any big news,
um they were, they were very small but they were a friend, so that's why it sucks,
I don't know maybe it did make big news, did false ID talk about it, I don't know, um
that's not kind of bad, what's not bad
Pinky told painting competition, what, why would it be a competition, what,
Melissa's doing even better in her pl, don't worry, I know she's doing good, I know she's doing good,
she's like, she's funny on her own, she's talented, she can do stuff on her own, like
a lot of people think that joining a company means that you'll get a lot of support
and I think, I think some people overestimate the amount of support, like they expect
and I think Mamosa is definitely, honestly all the girls are definitely better on their own
and anything, anything, like everything they've done they already did on their own, you know,
um, yeah you gotta be careful, especially with small companies, they can't really,
they might, they might promise something but you know, they might not go through with it
as we've seen from Yume Plus, as we've seen from Yume Plus,
do you still get many marshmallows Amy, I don't, I don't get as many anymore because I
can't answer them, would you like me to answer some, I feel like maybe I could answer some on stream
right now, most of them are just really lovey, or like telling you, telling, telling me about my day
or maybe a little bit corny, maybe a little bit corny, I know Amy made a lot of her own assets
or had them commissioned with her own money, yeah, yeah, only if you're comfortable,
is Viola a small, small company, I like to think so, yeah, I think we are, I feel like
once, I feel like once all of us pass 30k, then I think we'll be a little bit bigger,
but V2Bang is already so niche that like, no matter how big we get, I feel like it'll be hard to
ever be considered a sort of big company, because when I think of big companies, I think of like,
all alive, it'd be crazy to get as big as all alive, but I don't think so, I don't think so,
that's crazy, yes, and niche internet micro celebrity, yeah, small enough that the CEO is
one of its talents, I don't think that contributes to how small it is, I think that was just a
choice, that's just a choice, like it doesn't have anything to do with how small we are,
it's not like we need more talent, so the CEO stepped up and was like, I'll be a talent,
I think she just wanted to do that, you guys are going pretty far, oh thank you,
here, I can answer some marshmallows, but don't send anything corny right now, because we're on
YouTube, and I have to be like extra safe now, I have to be extra safe now unfortunately,
because I got a strike, because I got a strike here, let me send you
a marshmallow cut, I'm hungry, I'm gonna order sushi after this,
I'm gonna order sushi after this, there's a link, there's a link if you want to,
save it for brosley, yeah I could, I could, I could, yeah, I'm not sure when I'll do that,
I'm not sure when I'll do that, I hope soon, I hope,
should I show you, is that safe to show you, should be safe, the strikes go away,
they go away in like three months, so I have to be careful for three months,
um,
don't read out loud, what, what, do you want me to answer out loud, don't read out loud, what do you
mean, let me um, let me catch the marshmallow, oh that's not it, that's display capture, let me
catch the marshmallow website, and we can just chat a little bit and catch up to catch their, uh,
window,
oh here it is, um,
um, let me click this one first, it's a cat box, is this what I think it is,
um, okay I'll show this,
someone made a drawing for Esteban, oh thank you, it looks like her too,
I don't want to talk too much about her because I'll start to cry, but thank you,
I really appreciate it, I like it, I'll save that,
um, let me try to crop, crop, crop this so that it's uh, it's cropped to the, to the marshmallow,
there,
there we go, sorry chat, I'm covering you,
this has been a fun time so far, how are you doing, I'm super proud of you for hitting 20k,
I'm glad I became your big brother before this amazing time, I'm okay, I'm happy, I have to do
some sort of 30k celebration I guess too, I don't know, I don't want to do any more promised
celebrations until I can finish my um, other promised stuff for my other milestones,
because if I keep growing, then I'll have so many like celebrations stuff to do,
and I still have to finish the previous ones, um, let me, let me refresh the page,
Amy you're the best little sister, I love you so much, thank you, this one's funny,
is life even worth living knowing I can never get your cute little toes in my mouth, Amy,
it is, it is, you can always imagine my cute little toes in your mouth, you can always imagine it,
I know it's not as good as the real thing, but um, you should, you should continue even though you,
you can't have my toes in your mouth, princess carrying piggyback rides around the shoulders,
which is your preferred method of transportation by big friend, you guys have funny questions,
deep throat it, deep throat what the toes,
so real, real,
yeah we're gonna hit 40k pretty soon, I don't think so, but I, I, I, I want to get another video out,
and I have to be another um, I might have to be another like improv, I have like no time to
write scripts anymore because um, forlude audios is a lot for me, so I'm like, I'm banging the
mouth but I don't have script writing time, up to 34k, oh did we already reach 34k, no way,
where is me, where is me, where is me in my channel, oh we did reach 34k, thank you, thank you,
that's nice, thank you, um, preferred method of transportation,
I think I prefer piggyback rides, I never got much piggyback rides when I was a kid,
so I think I prefer piggyback rides, when I was a kid I would piggyback all of my friends,
because um, I don't know I just had weird friends that would always try to get on my back, and I was
like, you know how I tweeted out that I have like strong farm women jeans, I really do have strong
farm women jeans, so I would piggyback all my friends on my back because I was the strongest,
um, what is this, I know that the VLR discord server is only for stream notifications,
a big part of vtubing is for a community where fans can interact with each other,
any place I'm creating an official place where we can all share our love for Amy that isn't Twitter,
so I know that's a big part of vtubing, but it's not, um, like you guys can interact in the fan
server, the only problem is like we're not affiliated with that, but you guys can interact in
the fan server if you want, like make your own server, but um, like vtubing, like corporal vtubing
is like not, is not the same as like indie, so like um, a lot of companies stay away from official
servers with us in them, you know, with the talents in them, I don't understand why,
Amy, I like to hold through my screen during, during this stream, please do more feed streams,
you're gonna go through all of the, all of the, you're gonna go through all of your, all of your
monitors, let us groom you now, groom each other, my pin pals can groom each other, that's how you
can cope with not being able to groom me, yeah, many other companies don't have official discord
servers, yeah, don't touch discord with a 10 foot pole, I've, I, I trust me, I know the kind of crazy
fucking people on discord, I know, I'm aware, I've met them, I met a lot of them, and they're all crazy
there's always the free chat, yeah you guys could talk in free chat, I probably won't be there very
often, but like you can chat it to each other, yes there's a fanzir, you could just look it up on
reddit or something, like any, any, on twitter too, I know I probably shouldn't like, I probably shouldn't um
encourage it, but like, I don't know if you guys want to talk to each other, I feel bad saying like
no, what is your happiest memory, oh that's so depressing, fuck, um, my happiest memory
I don't know, I have a lot of my saddest memories, I don't have a lot of my happiest memories
can they be fixed though, some of them can, some of them need to be in jail
does it stink, what, being with your big bro
I guess one of my happier memories can be debuting, for sure, I don't want to say woman
brain, what do you mean, what do you mean, I take that back, fuck you, you're not allowed to be part
of my happiest memory, meeting us obviously, I think that's definitely one of them, maybe others
could be like quitting jobs, quitting jobs would be happy memories for me, because I didn't like
any of the ones I, I were at, I did, like I was at, which debut, both debut, both debuts, of course
um classic depression moment, yeah I don't, I can remember a lot of depressing moments, but I
can't remember a lot of happy moments, I don't know why, sorry, that's depressing, maybe getting
my rats, getting my rats, my first two rats was very happy too, I found a channel recently
because of your andy and lele games, you might like everything I see, keep at it and enjoy, thank you, thank you
um are there any streamers outside of the vtuber community who've influenced you slash you've
learned from? jibidoki kind of influenced me, my phone got a notification
jibidoki definitely influenced me because she's the first vtuber that was like kind of honest about
being like using a cute voice that I, that I saw, that I saw, that I like learned of, um
what other, oh wait outside of the vtuber community, oh outside of the vtuber community, sorry, sorry,
outside, uh outside, um well when I first started streaming um
I uh, I learned a lot from uh katlienta, unfortunately katlienta kind of sucks now
because she's like leaching off a vtuber drama on her channel, which I think is cringe, I'm sorry
I think it's cringe but back in the back a few months ago or a year ago katlienta made a lot of um
really helpful streaming advice like technical advice and just like just advice for how to stream,
how to be a better streamer especially for beginners and I learned a lot from from her tutorials um
so yeah I would say her um
in terms of like personality maybe, I also really like Jenna Marbles, my fucking, my life got
significant, my quality of life significantly decreased as soon as Jenna Marbles left youtube
like my depression meter raised to maximum when Jenna Marbles left youtube
so I'm really, I'm really um, I'm really uh
inspired by Jenna Marbles and like the kind of content she makes
what kind of guys do you like or what is your type of character or guys do you
prefer average macho man buff harry fanboys pretty far, I guess so many questions like this
I guess the only thing I don't like here I should show the question
the only thing I really really don't like is like super super buff guys um
I think a lot of guys misunderstand that girls want super buff guys and it's like no
at least not me I don't like buff um I hope your macho kind of got sorry
I don't like it ripped bros it's over sorry I don't know I just feel like
I feel like we wouldn't mesh well and also I just don't like that body type
role-voided kind yeah like big buff yeah yeah guys want super buff guys way more than women do
I feel like our our personality types and our lifestyles wouldn't match you know
like I I I am not waking up at 7am to go to the gym I'm not counting my calories I am not eating
plain chicken with rice I am not um drinking protein shakes and pushing those weights you know
like I will I will not come with you I will not come with you to the gym I will not participate in
that um and I I think it's I yeah we wake up at 5am yeah sorry buff penthouse it's over
I don't have the energy for that and I don't think I could beat with someone that has the
energy for that because it's like no no it just doesn't mesh with me the gains I know the gains
but like I don't know it's like it's not for me you know um chubby cook then he'll feed you
well honestly I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not opposed if you can cook I really like I really
like guys who can cook I really like guys who can cook guys who can cook dessert to other
tentacles sucked man I really like if you can cook like you you you got me first day
he's just cooking something for me I really like yeah um other than that like I like all of these
average um Harry I'm not too big on mostly because I was bullied for being Harry as a kid so now I'm
kind of disgusted by hair but as long as it's not excessive I don't really care that much you know
like as long as you don't have like chest hair back hair neck hair neck hair is crazy ear hair
nostril hair uh like all these combined sorry all these combined um fucking um toe hair like as long
as you don't have excessive hair in like in like um places that most people don't have excessive hair
you know beards are okay as long as they are groomed
it makes you feel better my only happy memory from last 10 years is the first time I saw you
and the one time I found free smack what that was dope wait what's smack I have to shave my
toes in my hands I do too I shaved my toes for this stream I shaved my toes for this
this exact stream so don't even worry about it you saw the image of the Mexican boy who wore
a flannel shirt with the black shirt under it except he was except he was he wasn't wearing a black
shirt no I have not seen that no yeah I love if you're a man who can groom if you're a groomer
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding would you like it if I made cheapy
clay figurines of either you or pin pal because I'm currently getting into making clay figurines
I'm still noob so if it looks rough then I'm sorry of course I like any any um any fan art you
can do I don't I don't care if it's bad you know um I don't care if you think it's bad I like I
like any fan art it's okay yeah and I I I like arts and crafts
where do you get your ideas from for what for what you gotta be more specific you can
groom me and we will groom each other my mom doesn't want me to shave she thinks I'll turn
into a monkey how does that work your hair doesn't grow back quicker if you shave
um for asmr I get my ideas from other asm artists for uh streams I get my ideas from
other streamers or other youtubers uh for art I get my ideas from other artists
I'm not original in the slightest basically just from other people
oh hold on I'm really I'm really sweaty right now let me get my fan out
shit do I even have my fan oh no
where's my fan oh here it is
olive creation is just paying homage to the things that inspire you to create yeah damn that's deep
real and true and deep
Amy you fed the flipbrows good today I need to see your butt in those yoga pants I don't really
have a butt I don't have a good butt man I don't literally oh my god it's so embarrassing so like
my cousin is really really interested not interested but like into taking pictures of herself
so when we went to all of these cool places and attractions I was basically her personal
photographer because she's like crazy about taking pictures of herself and like I I know
how to take pictures of people because I take a lot of anytime I take a picture I like take
forever to get the right angle so even though I don't take many pictures I know how to make
someone look a little bit better and um I was just her personal photographer and every time I
took a picture of her um I would be like damn like she looks good like work girl you know
but then we would take pictures together right and I I don't know how to pose in like full-body
pictures so like anytime we would get a picture together she'd be like posing like a model and
she'd look so freaking good like Instagram model level like fucking she would look so good and I
would just be standing there awkwardly she doesn't even smile like that's how model-esque
she tries to be and I I'm standing there I'm like way shorter than her and I look so awkward
standing next to her because I just stand there like awkwardly and it sucks to see all the pictures
with us because I'm like fuck man I'm so awkward next to her uh yeah that's just what that reminds
me of like I I I'm not good at I'm not gonna taking pictures of myself and I'm not gonna posing and
um I don't think I could get a good butt picture like Strani's butt picture was good I don't think
I'd be able to pose like that I I'd be like hunched over I'd be hunched over like a crab
they're not like a crab like a shrimp tear hot chocolate before you get tucked into bed uh
hot chocolate hot chocolate ask her for tips I should she gets a lot of good pictures of herself
I'm so shit at it what are your three sizes suck my dick Canadian toes with real 100% maple syrup
that's a dream I never want to wake up and I never want to wake up my cousin tried Canadian
maple syrup for the first time and she really liked it too um maple syrup is yummy we should we
should uh should I just start feeding all the foot pros every stream food stream where I where I
just stuff my feet in all the food I mean your butt picture will look amazing I don't care what you
say is that my face on your on your profile picture thank you thank you um I mean can you
please give us a kiss before you go love you sure do you work out no I don't I'm trying to do yoga
lately I'm on day two um I don't really do it now um I should go holy shit
sorry if this is too imposing but I was wondering if you'd consider joining in on the
feed tubers versus feet uh trend that some of the other veiler members have been doing on exeter um
maybe I probably would just post like a picture of my feet that I already have I don't think I'd
post a new picture of my feet just because it's a lot of effort you know it's a lot of effort
um I'm just here to see someone drawing with the toes reminds me of an archer who
exclusively shot with her feet oh I know that I know that archer I've seen that
um I could I could I guess I'd have to take a screenshot of my model you know I'm kind of lazy
junk just link this stream no I wanted to be good I want to look good this dream looks like
shit I have markers all over my toes um will you ever build a gunpla on stream I don't I uh
I don't I don't know how I don't really know what those are I know they're like robot um
maybe I don't I don't know anything about them though I'm not really much of a
I never I didn't have a lot of uh exposure to like Japanese stuff
um someone asked me what I like to nut to
um
literature I usually don't look at anything I I usually just
I'm cultured like that I'm cultured like that
what's the most memorable stream you've ever watched I don't watch a lot of streams anymore
because I don't have time um honestly the memorable streams I've watched are just like
the debuts of my vtuber children so them have had like you know little mini debuts with their
models that I made and that was cool I liked watching those
do chicks get posed in the clarity sometimes sometimes you ever finished this might you were
reading way back oh I didn't I really should shouldn't die maybe I really do want to maybe
once because I wanted to record one more audio before I go to bed today so maybe once I'm done
that I can try longer books or shorter stories I like both as long as they're good I would I
like both as long as they're good do you remember that it means amazing artists thank you you have
any fears about the current us election in terms of posting nsfw content I ask this due to the
current opposition being interested in banning it all together um I didn't know that was happening
I'm not I don't live in America so um I will continue to post nsfw content um I didn't know
this was happening um sorry to anyone who lives in America and might not be able to see it anymore
but I will be continuing to post it use the VPN use the VPN why are you so cute and funny I don't
know uh any plans to do a member's tarot card stream I saw some people were interested in that
I guess I could I don't know if I already have a member stream next week I think next week is
an ASMR member stream they're banning goons apparently I don't know first I've heard of it I don't know
if you're all though I'm gonna say showing us your tax returns are more smexy than anything
why do you want to see my tax returns you think I pay taxes okay um I could I don't I'm not good
at tarot am I even pronouncing it wrong is it is am I pronouncing it right is a tarot or tarot
I don't know I'm not good at it um I will have like a I will have a
uh I'll have my my book I'll have my book next to me tarot okay tarot tarot tarot
tarot tarot what ain't no way I thought it was tarot at least tarot not tarot tarot
tarot yeah tarot tarot okay um I some people consider themselves to be very like spiritually
in tuned and like really really are really into it and like claim to be able to talk to spirits
or like the spirits guide them I am not like that um I think those people might be a little bit
delusional and I like being delusional and I wish I could be that delusional okay is it offensive
to call them delusional maybe but I'm saying I want to be like them okay I want to be like them
so yes sure but it's not gonna I'm not gonna be like oh the spirits are telling me that your
grandma's gonna fucking die tomorrow like I'm not gonna be specific um I'm not gonna be like oh the
cards they're leading me they're leading me um to to this direction there's evil in your life
I'll be like oh you got the you got the tarot card okay uh hold on let me look through my book to see
what that means hold on let me let me scroll through let me scroll through my kindle
to see what the fuck that means oh um it means uh fucking I don't know look out for your future
like I don't fucking know the cards led me to the street
yeah delulu recognizes delulu I just feel like somebody might be offended by me calling them
delulu but I'm saying that like I want to be like that I want to be that leveled to that level but
I just can't did you ever expect to get this many sub slash followers no I thought I was gonna be
the least subscribed member I thought I was gonna be I thought I was gonna be the least popular
member when I first joined a look I told stroney that she didn't really react but I was like
I thought I was gonna be the least subscribed do you wear glasses contacts or have 2020 vision
no I wear glasses sometimes I wear contacts but not much I am I don't have 2020 vision
um she's saying it lovingly yeah like I don't I don't mean it in a
uh I don't mean in an offensive way I'm just like it's some people are very uh
outgoing about their spiritual beliefs
tarot is complicated but becomes significantly easier to understand if you
ignore it completely except when playing persona games huh
oh classic pessimistic sis
yes I am a pessimist
this is very important to for a future project please provide a simple yes slash no
to the petty crimes listed below that you'd be willing to commit with big bro
shoplifting yes egging a house yes aggressive behavior at home yes dine and dash no removal
of property yes loitering yes trespassing yes simple assault yes public intoxication yes
disturbance of peace no stealing a street sign yes defacing yes there you go
there you go
any thoughts on the rituals have been felted I saw one did you guys send me more than one hold on
I did see one I thought it was cute I thought it was cute I liked it did you send me more than one
she she said yes on stealing street signs let's go yeah
I'm not saying I've done any of that before you don't have to lock me up just yet
um may you perhaps possibly maybe say
is that offensive what does that mean I don't
oh shit did my phone just die no it didn't a ritual yeah the fin felt send me a picture of a ritual
they did you strike me as a type of person who has a pen pal and unironically enjoys it
and though I don't have I don't have a pen pal I only have a pin pal is what offensive
I don't know is this someone just said someone asked me to say something but I'm scared of saying
I'm scared of saying things that people tell me to tell me to say because what if it's offensive
what does that mean is that your name do you want me to call you cool
uh can you sing for us
I have it was bad because I was drunk who the fuck is chewing on my feet
uh Pixie's chewing not chewing but liking my toes
is it weird to listen to corn ASMR roleplay audios to fall asleep to I really love your voice
I think you're cute no it's not weird it's the most it's the the that's the most uh like the most
amount of ASMR I've made is like that so drunk in me hit every note drunk in me missed every note
um maybe one day I'll do another one I really want to do a stream where I practice um
I really want to do a stream where I practice uh deeper songs because I feel like that's where
my voice really sounds the best I don't know why you would think I'd be able to do really high
pitch songs you would think I'd be able to I can't I I I feel like it sounds really croaky
and like whiny but deeper sounds like a little nicer so I really want to do a stream
where like karaoke stream where I practice those it would have to be on archive probably
probably
thank you to the person who reminds me to take my birth control every day
the singing was peak please bless us again it was so bad I ow fuck who's biting
someone bit my fucking toe it was I thought it was good in the moment but that's because
I was drunk like in the moment I was like fuck yeah I sound so good right now and then I listened
back to the stream and I was like holy shit I was not hearing myself accurately what's the highest
note you can make I don't know I don't know notes like that like I'm not a professional singer I
can't be like oh yeah the highest note I can make is a seven like I don't know what that means then
I can go my when I got a singing singing teacher she said I was a oh what did she say I was
uh
she said I was a let me alone add block
singing categories right like a different
she said I was a soprano I feel like I'm not a soprano though because anytime I try to sing
high pitched I sound like shit I sound like shit and then anytime I try to sing deeper I'm like
this sounds better
can you go queen type of high pitched I don't I don't what is what is queen type of high pitched
you want me to scream the highest note
I have no more juice left
there you go bless you thank you
you
Amy you said you like cheese you have any particular favorite kind um I'm a casual not a casual I
really like cheese sounds like a recorder tea kettle's broke it sounds like a flute oh thank you for
the compliments your high pitch sounds like you were blowing through a flute it gave me a jump
scare oh I feel like it just sounded like an annoying yell it sounds like an annoying cheese
a cheese an annoying scream um I like brie I like brie cheese a lot that's my favorite kind of cheese
don't be regarded karaoke stream is 10 out of 10 I still ferried up once or twice a week
still wishing you didn't mute
every day people cry because I didn't because I I muted while I was puking
brie is good brie is good I like to microwave brie with the honey or maple syrup and dip stuff in
inside of it when you said you liked men sounding whiny during activities what do you
exactly mean by that pitch cadence personality can you give me an example all of them all of them
um all of them example
like
there's always next time you get drunk to not mute there is I don't know when I'll get drunk
again because I those times felt like they made me feel like shit so I'll need a break um so I come
here pixie she was right next to me came it I listen to a lot of I'm I'm a I'm a I'm a gooner
myself I listen to a lot of um boyfriend asmr not as much anymore but I went through a phase
where I listened to a lot and I noticed that a lot of guys like artificially deeps of course you do
shut up I've noticed that a lot of guys artificially deep into their voice
and I just was like I just really I'm not gonna like my favorites I'm not gonna like my favorites
I don't really I only had one of favorite ever and they've luck and deleted their channel so
you can't even find it wait a minute
oh man
I think my I think pixie and Luna might have some problems with mites I'm seeing little dots on
them why do my why do my rats always have to suffer anyways um I can't link the one that
piqued my interest they're gone and they deleted their fucking channel probably because they saw
me and they were like uh ew she listens to my content okay I'm kidding um free with grilled
chicken and sounds oh sandwich with that pesto sauce I actually don't really like pesto sauce that much
um
yeah male ASMR artists do exist yeah
um but yeah they like artificially like they go like not with AI but like they they just
voice act lower they're like hey baby
me
do you know what I mean like they try to go out grievely and I was I it was always so
it was so unattractive so when I say whiny I mean like just sound like yourself sound like
yourself don't try to sound sexy like like I don't know and I like whiny because like I think it's
cute um pretentious have you ever watched those chris ASMR videos I have I have they're funny
we need to all become ASMR artists so Amy can goon
whiny how like spongebob no oh my god like um
um
like normal I don't know explain it like sound like yourself but like whine a little bit
don't sound like spongebob don't be like ah oh my god Amy ah Amy that feels so good
I do ASMR for my subs once a month oh that's cool I do a lot more than once um
is that a dolphin no it's spongebob
it's spongebob
like I have no clue how to explain it other than just sound like yourself okay
don't don't try to sound sexy because when you try to sound sexy it gets cringe
just sound like yourself you know even I cringe when I sound when I try to sound sexy I'm like
ew that's cringe
that's a dolphin how does spongebob laugh then
I don't fucking know
don't laugh like spongebob in your tribute please please please
why does so many vtubers talk about their pets because they're part of our lives and their
family and I kind of felt bad because I kind of got you a little bit of attached a little
bit attached to my pets and if I if they just suddenly disappeared and I never explained anything
to you about them I don't you know I want you to know what happened to them you know what happens
with them um what do you think about people who eat instant noodles with rice and if it's not with
rice if it's not with rice it won't be considered a meal and just a snack
it's so specific I like instant noodles with rice okay let's eat instant noodles with rice together
I don't know oh I hate this question do you have a mommy a dummy mommy voice I have a blue color
with white dog bones and paw prints that I'm wearing if you want to go on walkies with your big
bro please call me a good boy oh my god okay what is noodles with rice like instant noodles
rice
carbs with carbs I love carbs I love carbs at cholesterol I love cholesterol
I love fat
okay sorry I just I think it's cringe when people are like you don't eat that there's so many carbs in
it krill yourself um
oh you cook instant noodles and put a scoop of white rice in it oh that sounds good that sounds
good that sounds good I like that do you have friends you're my friend
oh answer the question okay I feel like ever I feel like ever since um
like I feel like because of uh what's your name what's the raccoon girl's name
raccoon girl raccoon girl like I feel like a lot of youtubers are good at voice acting right
snuffy snuffy's good at voice acting um I once suggested to scrawny that maybe a concept art
could be made where all the pets of valor could be in mascot costumes or rats as pen pals for example
that's cute that's really cute thank you for the ten dollars that's really cute like because a lot of
youtubers are good at voice acting like snuffy's got a really hot voice a fucking um omelette's got
a really hot voice even um like serenity has a really good mommy voice um what's the other ones
uh shondo can even sound deep and mommy like I I feel like people just automatically assume
that um everyone can sound mommy um and I I I am not a great voice actor I'm a one trick pony
I'm a one trick pony a lot of good voice actors can also sing too
which I am jealous of if I can't sing I'll get there I'm working on it you ever hear
sarah's ser uh fauna's deep voice I haven't know but I bet she sounds hot as shit
it's a really good trick sponge yeah even fucking spongebob's got a mommy voice
shondo's cute and funny she is cute and funny stop lying you can sing okay
meow you didn't do vocal impressions of any other vealer members I tried that in my member
stream and it ended epically I don't want to try again
I could call you a good boy in my voice you're a good boy
would you ever want audio corner p from pin pals yes I like it when you send that send more
do you ever go into audios from other vealer gen mates no we do not send each other our
audios we do not send each other audios if I want to if I wanted to hear it I'd have to subscribe
and I feel like that's weird that's weird that's weird I don't want to do that that's weird
I I don't know I have heard like I've heard them like on twitter though
and I feel like it's weird to go on twitter too I feel like it's weird
it's weird to go to them on twitter too no I don't want to go to my friends
comment OMG I I nodded to this thank you so much for posting this shivy I just came so hard
to clean up on aisle my pants
like I I wouldn't I can't like a volcano
did you get my wedding invitation was the deal not good enough wait I didn't even see a wedding
invitation I'm sorry I haven't been keeping up with marshmallows as well as I should
I didn't forget about our marriage form it was a joke the tweet was a joke
in me the marriage form I tweeted that I couldn't show you my babas because I
we're not married if you could do it who would you do it to oh if I could choose no I could
no no I can't choose like that no that's weird to say that's weird to say no
confession I goon to the sound of my sister's voice disgusting
what you never many in me honey to the audio straw you posted on her
you never made it no I don't I don't listen I don't I don't seek out their
audios if it's if I'm scrolling through twitter and it plays then that's fine but I don't seek
out their audios it's funny that you think I do um if someone were to make a yandere
rp for you would you rather be the target or the yandere one I'd rather be the target
I'm the I'm I wouldn't be the target
dear lord you're so cute they love you so much thank you
an off collab with one of the other girls and bringing some two-player toys along oh my god
you guys are so preferred oh my god interesting ideas
um no no no no only an only no
um we only audio only audio collab
okay I'm getting sweaty is anyone still streaming I I kept going for too long
okay Rina's still streaming I don't feel like I need a fan
I know you like the idea but I don't know I feel like
I feel like it would be like cheating on you you know
um the acer where you did with ac way back was probably one of your best ones can we
expect another one like that one day way back do you mean the patreon one that came out like a while
go
we can set that we'll bring the chair the cuck chair we'll go to a hotel every hotel has a good
cuck chair and me and I see you can watch me and I see from the cuck chair
way back don't you mean the youtube one there's a youtube one and a patreon one the youtube one is
just um it's mostly ASMR triggers we do talk a little bit in that one
maybe I have to ask I see I think I think we'll have one on her channel I would like to do one
on her channel I asked strongy for one on her channel has anyone roasted you to the point of crying
um
like roasted in like a roast off like where we were all roasting each other no
because I've never I've never been in like a roast competition so no not the chair
I want a continuation for the slime ASMR but in patreon
once I once I get my life together it's over for you bitches I will be I would be
making so much content once I get my life together you would be you would be nutting every day to the
the amount of quality content I could make once I get my life together
I want all the in me content it'll happen eventually
what's the first game you're gonna play on fancy I don't know I wasn't sure what I was gonna do I was
thinking of testing out the bear I think that would be fun you think that would be fun I think
that would be fun to test of the bear the bear it would be a fun thing but I feel like I should
also use one of those like chat controlled like don't know controlled toys you know
um both of those are good ideas but I I can't tell you before I wouldn't even I wouldn't even
know what I was streaming until like 10 minutes before the stream so playing things out for me
is like crazy I don't plan I'm not a planner she's cooking your honor yeah I would like to I would
like to play with it I think that would be fun you could do a normal gaming stream except you
play the game also playing with your handheld fan what would I play Minecraft you want to see me play
you want to see me play play uh bed wars well in bed did you already set up subs no I haven't
even set that up I only got verified that's all I've done what's wrong with the bear it's cool
what's the bear
it's um it's a bear with an attachment we can all take turns in the archer
absolutely not no I will not be having a train uh uh okay okay okay okay I'll I'll I'll and now
I gotta shut my mouth up um the bear looks cursed I it is cursed but it's cursed in a fun way and
that's why I want to try it okay okay I'm gonna let you off to rain's stream um please support
all the yume plus girls unfortunately reya is going on hiatus but you can still support rain
you can still support maryl I think I think you can still support maryl um you can still support
fuck I don't remember moses peel it's like rune hanakawa okay that that's that's the
name before she changed you can support her rune something rune she changed it to something new
and I don't know how to pronounce it but you should support her too um yeah because they went
through a lot yeah um and I'll leave you off with that thank you for coming to our 20k celebration
um thank you for watching um
I'll see you I think tomorrow but only if you're a member tomorrow's a member stream
we'll be writing um my little pony fanfiction um I love you a lot um thank you for all the nice
marshmallows you sent me earlier today um and the day before too
I'll I'll see you I'll see you tomorrow okay bye
um